you have spoken about and thought about
nuclear war a lot
uh over the past year we've
seemingly have come
closest to the precipice of nuclear war
than uh at least in my lifetime
yeah what do you learn about human
nature from that it's our old friend
molok again it's really scary to see it
where
America doesn't want there to be a
nuclear war Russia doesn't want to be a
global nuclear war either we know we
both know that it would just be another
if we just try to do it it both sides
try to launch first it's just another
suicide race right so why are we why is
it the way you said that this is the
closest we've come since 1962. in fact I
think we've come closer now than even
the Cuban Missile Crisis it's because of
molok you know you you have these other
forces
on one hand you have um the West
saying that uh we have to drive Russia
out of Ukraine it's a matter of Pride
and we've staked so much on it that it
would be seen as a huge
loss of The credibility of the West if
we don't drive Russia out entirely of
the Ukraine
and on the other hand you have Russia
who
has um and you have the Russian
leadership who knows that if they get
completely driven out of Ukraine you
know
it might it's not just going to be very
humiliating for them but they might it
often happens when countries lose Wars
that things don't go so well for their
leadership either like you remember when
Argentina invaded the Falkland Islands
the the military Junta that ordered that
right people are cheering on the streets
at first when they are when they took it
and then when they got their butt kicked
by the British you know what happened to
those guys
they were out and I believe those were
still alive or in jail now right so so
you know the Russian leadership is
entirely cornered where they know that
just
getting driven out of Ukraine is not an
option
um and um
so this to me is a typical example of
molecu you have these incentives of the
two parties
where both of them are just driven to
escalate more and more right if Russia
starts losing in the conventional
Warfare
the only thing they can do is to sit
back against the war is to keep
escalating and but and the West has put
itself in the in the situation now where
sort of already committed that the drive
rush out so the only option the West has
is to call Russ's Bluff and keep sending
in more weapons
this really bothers me because moloch
can sometimes Drive competing parties to
do something which is ultimately just
really bad for both of them
and uh you know what makes me even more
worried is not just that I
it's
difficult to see an ending
a quick peaceful ending to this tragedy
that doesn't involve some horrible
escalation
um but also that we understand more
clearly now just how horrible it was
gonna it would be
there was an amazing paper that was
published in nature food this uh August
by some of the top researchers who've
been studying nuclear winter for a long
time and what they basically did was
they combined
climate models
with
food agricultural models so instead of
just saying yeah you know it gets really
cold blah blah they figured out actually
how many people would die in the
different different countries
and it's uh it's pretty mind-blowing you
know so basically what happens you know
is the thing that kills the most people
is not the explosions it's not the
radioactivity it's not the EMP Mayhem
it's not the right
the rampaging mobs foraging food no it's
it's the fact that you get so much smoke
coming up from the burning cities into
the stratosphere that
um
spreads around the earth from the jet
streams so
in typical models you get like 10 years
or so where it's just crazy cold
during the first year or after the the
war
and their models
the temperature drops in in Nebraska and
in the Ukraine bread baskets you know by
like
20 Celsius or so if I remember
no yeah 2030 Celsius depending on where
you are 40 so it's just in some places
which is you know 40 Fahrenheit to 80
Fahrenheit colder than what it would
normally be
so you know I'm not good at farming but
uh it's knowing if it drops below
freezing pretty much almost days in July
and then like that's not good so they
worked out they put this into their
farming models and what they found was
really interesting the countries that
get the most hard hit are the ones in
the northern hemisphere
so in in the U.S
and and one model they had about 99 of
all Americans starving to death
in Russia and China and Europe also
about 99 98 starving to death
so you might be like oh it's kind of
poetic justice that both the Russians
and the Americans
99 of them have to pay for it because it
was their bombs that did it but you know
that doesn't particularly cheer people
up in Sweden or other random countries
that have nothing to do with it right
and um
hit the
I think it hasn't entered the mainstream
uh
not understanding very much just like
how bad this is most people
especially a lot of people in decision
making positions still think of nuclear
weapons as something that makes you
powerful
uh scary powerful and they don't think
of it as something where uh yeah just
to within a percent or two you know
we're all just just gonna starve to
death
and um and starving to death is
is
um
the worst way to die as colada more is
all all the families in history show
the torture involved in that probably
brings out the worst in people also when
when people are desperate like this it's
not so some people I've heard some
people say that if that's what's gonna
happen there'd rather be at Ground Zero
and just get vaporized you know
and but uh
so but I think people underestimate the
risk of this because they they
aren't afraid of Morlock they think oh
it's just gonna be because humans don't
want this so it's not going to happen
that's the whole point the mark that
things happened that nobody wanted and
that applies to nuclear weapons and that
applies to AGI
exactly and it applies to some of the
things that people have gotten most
upset with capitalism for also right
where everybody was just kind of Trapped
you know
it's not to see if some company does
something
that causes a lot of harm and not that
the CEO is a bad person but she or he
knew that you know that the other all
the other companies were doing this too
so monologue is um
as a former foe I hope for someone they
can make make good movies so we could
see who the real enemy is so we don't
because we're not fighting against each
other uh molok makes us fight against
each other that's small that's what
mollusk superpower is
The Hope here is any kind of technology
or other mechanism that lets us instead
realize
that we're fighting the wrong anime
right now it's such a fascinating battle
system it's US versus it
yeah yeah we are fighting Malik for
human survival we as a civilization have
you seen the movie Needful Things
it's a Stephen King novel I love Stephen
King and uh Max von seed of Swedish
actors playing the guys it's brilliant
exactly I just thought I hadn't thought
about that until now but that's the
closest I've seen to a a movie about
moloch I don't want to spoil the film
for anyone who wants to watch it but
basically
it's about this guy who turns out that
you can interpret him as the devil or
whatever but he doesn't actually ever go
around and kill people or torture people
will go burning coal or anything
he makes everybody fight each other it
makes everybody hate fear each other
hate each other and then kill each other
so that that's the movie about moloch
you know love is the answer that seems
to be
um
one of the ways to fight
Malik is by um compassion by seeing the
common Humanity yes yes and to not sound
so we don't sound like like uh what's
the Kumbaya Tree Huggers here right
[Laughter]
we're not just saying love and peace man
we're trying to actually help people
understand the true facts
about the other side
and feel the compassion
because
the truth makes you more compassionate
right
so I I that's why I really like using AI
for truth and for truth seeking
Technologies can
that can uh as a result you know get us
more love than hate and
and even if you can't get love you know
settle for settle for some understanding
which already gives compassion if
someone is like you know
I really disagree with you
Lex but I can see why you're where
you're coming from you're not a a bad
person who needs to be destroyed but I
disagree with you and I'm happy to have
an argument about it you know that's a
lot of progress compared to where we are
2023 in the public space wouldn't you
say